okay so I finally played Star Wars Jedi
Fallen order and you guys were right
this game is freaking awesome all right
what do we actually get
no freaking way
oh my gosh that is so cool now growing
up when I played a lot of video games I
almost always played on release date
well as I've gotten older that just
isn't the case anymore I can't always do
that because of other obligations in
life so it's always interesting for me
to go back to a game that a lot of
people have hyped up because once you're
sort of out of that release window what
does that actually like to just go in
and experience the game itself well in
this case in the case of Fallen order
I'm happy to say that I am really
enjoying my time so far I'm about six
hours in and we've actually been live
streaming this over on Twitch and so
today I just want to talk about a few of
the ways that this game Wows you in the
first three hours and several of these
things I did not expect at all and for
such a high profile game it's kind of
surprising to me that I was able to
avoid mostly all spoilers I know
actually very little about this game I'd
heard there was definitely some Souls
inspiration which I'm a huge fan of the
Souls game so I was totally on board for
that but other than that I didn't know
much about the story didn't know much
about the main character so it's really
been fun to go into this as has a
completely fresh experience and I have
to say without a doubt the first thing
that grabbed me was just the overall
cinematic feel now Star Wars games over
the years of course they've been hit or
miss some have been great some have been
okay some have been just bad but it's
clear right from the jump of this one
they wanted you to be invested in this
story they wanted you to care about
these characters that are here so the
voice acting is great the dialogue is
really good there's almost immediately
this mystery that you're curious to know
more about actually I wasn't even sure
if Cal knew whether or not he was a Jedi
yet and don't worry that question is
answered pretty quickly if you haven't
played the game before but it's not just
the cutscenes that they tell this
through it's also through the actual
gameplay when you're moving through the
world you're having these conversations
with characters and the game that I
thought of almost right away was
Uncharted so I had a pretty good feeling
going in that it was going to be solid
as far as gameplay and the action and
all that which we'll get to that here in
a bit but that cinematic feel of
Uncharted even the climbing felt very
much like Uncharted and you know whether
you love or hate dog you can't deny
their ability to tell a story with just
a cinematic feel as if you're watching a
big budget movie now again I'm just a
few hours in so the storytelling could
fall completely apart as I progress to
the game but so far I'm actually kind of
curious about the story and what's going
to happen as we move forward but it's
not even just the what's going to happen
it's the way that they're telling this
story I already am invested in this
character Cal and as good as the action
is it's all these in-between moments
these little moments with the Droid bd1
that you have from very early on that I
think really helped with the whole and
honestly make me even more excited for
the sequel but of course I need to beat
this one first alright I said we would
get to the action we have to talk about
the combat in this game look anytime you
put a lightsaber in your hands in a
video game it's gonna be fun even if the
game itself is bad as long as you have
the ability to swing the lightsaber at
least that one act will be fun I
remember playing I think it was Star
Wars Jedi power battles as a kid this
game did not review well at all however
as a kid I still kind of loved it and I
think a big part of that was the
lightsaber action it's just one of those
iconic weapons you know that when you
have it in your hand there's something
very special about that moment and they
really really lean into that with this
game and so one of the very first things
you can do with a lightsaber is that you
can deflect back the Stormtrooper blast
and it just feels so good there's no
like on-screen indicator there's not a
big prompt over your head that flashes
and said now is when you need to block
you have to actually watch the
Stormtrooper look ahead wait for their
incoming shot and then quickly deflect
now if you just hold it down you'll be
able to deflect everything no problem
until your stamina wears down but it's
not going to do any damage to them it
just deflects back however if you time
it just right it will actually deflect
it right back at them for an instant KO
I'm even playing on the I think it's
Jedi Master difficulty which is not
quite the top range of difficulty but
even there if you time it just right it
one shots the Storm Troopers and it
feels so good when you time this and I
don't know how it's going to change and
evolve as I go through the game but
immediately that is why one thing that I
just absolutely loved right from the
get-go now my second thing that I
absolutely love is another one about the
combat and it's sort of to do with the
timing because whenever you get the
timing just right on these parries
you'll be able to execute these
finishing attacks and they have all
sorts of fun little animations for these
finishers and this is really where I
think you start to see those influences
of the souls games because yet there are
some enemies here that you meet early on
you can run around and just take them
out without much thought but also pretty
early on you're going to run some
enemies that if you're too aggressive if
you get too greedy if you don't time
your attacks just right you will pay you
will die and you will have to keep
coming back and fighting again and again
and I know there's a lot of people who
just kind of hate this gameplay mechanic
but there's also a lot of people who
love it don't get me wrong I enjoy a
good Hack and Slash and just being able
to go in and go crazy but for me
personally if I had to pick just one I
would definitely pick that more
methodical approach where you actually
have to put some thought into it before
you go into the fight and that actually
ties very well into my next point of
what has impressed me so far and that's
just the overall I guess you could say
difficulty slash progression just feels
weird to call A Game's difficulty like a
strength or something that stood out
especially since there are difficulty
options so you can kind of cater this to
your needs and what you're interested in
but it's not just the difficulty it's
also this sense of progression that you
get from very early on in this game I
mean you're introduced to this initial
planet after kind of that tutorial area
and they just sort of trickle in these
little mechanics that they're going to
teach you one by one and again overall
I'm about six hours in but so far that
hasn't stopped it's been this steady
drip of new information of new details
of new mechanics that I've been able to
use as my character I feel like
progression is one of those really
tricky things for games to nail because
people play games in so many different
ways and especially the more open a game
is I think that makes it even harder so
I wouldn't say this game is necessarily
like a fully open world game but it is
free roam in a sense you can go to these
planets roam about the world find these
little upgrades and I feel like the more
choice you give a player it makes it
even harder for a developer to kind of
craft that experience of knowing what
your progression will be like through a
game but I definitely prefer when
developers give you the option to go to
an area and then be like okay wow this
is way too difficult maybe I can come
back and do this later and so you get
that very early in this game after you
complete the first planet there are two
additional planets that you have the
option to go to and it's funny my chat
was saying half of them were saying not
to go to this planet that it was too
hard and the other half was saying no go
it's definitely worth it you want to get
the reward there so I did decide to go
ahead and go to this planet daithamir
and while it was definitely more
difficult than that first planet I
actually enjoyed it I enjoyed trying to
figure out how to get through this level
without having all the upgrades that you
probably would if you came there later
and the reward was definitely worth it
now speaking of progression and upgrades
and things like that that is the other
thing that really stood out to me is
pretty quickly in this game you start
unlocking all of these different force
abilities so it's not just about the
lightsaber of course when it comes to a
Jedi one of the early ones you unlock is
wall all running and while running it's
a tricky thing to get just right but I
think it feels pretty good here it
certainly opens up several other areas
for you that you don't have immediate
access to so I think there's going to be
a bit of a metroidvania going on here
where you're gonna have to backtrack
which I'm personally okay with I know
some people don't love that but I don't
mind it at all I love coming back and
exploring planets again with all these
new upgrades that I found so I can do
even more find even more so I'm actually
looking forward to that and so we've
talked about the cinematics we've talked
about the action the force upgrades
though they also are going to play a
major role in Puzzles oh and speaking of
puzzles one thing I absolutely love that
every developer should just copy exactly
this and bring it over with the map in
this game you'll have green areas red
areas and yellow areas and for someone
like me who's a completionist I like to
look and try to find everything as much
as I can this is so so helpful so
basically what it means when you see a
red door that means you can't go here
you do not have the ability to progress
there yes I know I don't need to waste
my time even going in looking at that
area at all green means that you can you
do have the ability to go there you can
get through that area right now with
your current level and yellow means it's
an unexplored area and so far I've
really been enjoying the system I just
think it's a fantastic quality of life I
would say now guys if you've missed any
of these live streams we are posting
those to our dedicated let's play
Channel I'll link it here on the right
side of your screen as always thank you
all so much for watching I'll talk to
you again soon